-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well,
and now we're going to
get to the news.
President Biden announced
yesterday
that the U.S. is banning
all imports
of Russian gas and energy.
And then, for emphasis,
he biked away.
[ Laughter ]
House Democrats are set to
travel to Philadelphia tomorrow
for their annual
three-day retreat,
and Biden's already
practicing his trust falls.
[ Laughter ]
Dude!
You're supposed to wait
for another person.
The United Nations
has reportedly instructed
its communications staff
not to describe the conflict in
Ukraine as a war or an invasion.
How else would you describe it?
Oh, it's just
a little uninvited drop-in.
No worse than Urkel.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Ted Cruz
claimed during a recent meeting
that almost every time he flies,
the captain or flight attendant
will hug him because he does not
support vaccine mandates.
Are you sure
they're hugging you?
They might be trying to
wrestle you off the plane
and back to your job.
"Well, thank you very much."
"We're not thanking you!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden told Americans
yesterday
to expect higher gasoline prices
amid the Russian invasion
of Ukraine
and called it
"Putin's price hike."
Also, he has some bad news
about Putin's
prescription drug prices.
"Ah, I'm gonna try to
sneak that one in, too."
Republican Senator Susan Collins
met yesterday
with President Biden's
Supreme Court nominee,
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson,
for 90 minutes.
"After meeting with her,
I don't think she's qualified
for the position,"
said Judge Jackson.
[ Laughter ]
Researchers at
the University of Georgia
said last week
that the East Coast
is set to be inundated this
spring by the joro spider,
a large invasive species
that uses its webs like
a parachute in order to fly.
Which brings us to
our new segment -- "Not Now."
♪♪
Not now, joro spider!
Read the room.
We're still dealing
with a deadly pandemic,
a war in Ukraine, global
warming, and rampant crime.
You can't even get swatted
with a newspaper
because we need the newspaper
to actually read
if it's safe to go outside.
Not now!
Oh, you know the CDC isn't
going to be able to handle this.
They'll announce
that we should all be
stomping the joro spiders,
then two days later,
they'll be like, "Wait, wait!
No, stomping
just makes them mad!"
Seriously.
Please, not now.
If we get infested
with spiders now,
we can't even afford the gas
to burn our houses down.
Not now, joro spiders!
-This has been "Not Now."
-The athletic apparel
brand Lululemon yesterday
unveiled
its first-ever running shoe.
The sneaker will give you the
grip and the support you need
when you're demanding
to speak to a manager.
[ Laughter ]
Today was Donald Trump Jr.'s
fiancée, Kimberly Guilfoyle,
53rd birthday.
And don't worry about
getting her anything --
she already has
what she deserves.
[ Laughter ]
Charles Entenmann of the famous
Entenmann's baked-good franchise
has died at the age of 92.
Said moms,
"Ehh, should still be good."
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, we have a...
we have a brand-new writer
who thought that joke would --
What's that?
Oh, it was
head writer Alex Baze...
who's been doing this longer
than anyone.
"They're gonna love it!
People love Entenmann's cake.
They'll love a joke
about how the guy died."
[ Laughter ]
Yet, I had to do it.
You know why?
'Cause I'm scared of him.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
Okay, that's better.
He's not really dead.
He is? Oh, he is.
A man in Georgia was recently --
[ Laughter ]
This is all --
Baze wrote that part, too.
A man in Georgia
was recently sentenced
to three years in prison
for allegedly using part of
a coronavirus relief loan
to buy a Pokémon trading card.
Or, as he's telling
his cellmates, killing a guy.
[ Laughter ]
Amid retirement rumors,
Green Bay Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers
has reportedly decided
to remain with the team
for at least one more variant.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new poll,
39% of New Yorkers said that
they're planning to
move out of the state.
Said their friends,
"Uhh, I'm busy that weekend."
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.